POLICE RAID:
January 20, 2012.
The New Zealand police uses their anti-terrorism
special tactics group to illegally raid a
$32 million mansion with 76 officers and 2
helicopters.
Reason?
A special request from the FBI.
Target?
Kim Dotcom, an apparant international terrorist.
The police would not only arrest Kim but also
seize 18 luxury cars, $175 million in cash,
and 64 of his bank accounts.
This wasn’t just some random off the cuff
raid either.
New Zealand’s Security Bureau had been stalking
Kim for weeks before the raid, but those few
weeks were nothing.
Rumors started flying around that the prime
minister of New Zealand, John Key, was in
on the plan for years.
Apparently, the only reason he granted Kim
residency in the first place was so that he
could one day raid and extradite Kim.
It wasn’t just New Zealand’s PM that was
allegedly in on the plan either.
US president Barack Obama had allegedly been
colluding with Hollywood the entire time to
orchestrate the entire plan.
What did Kim do that was so vile and apprehensible?
Well, he was the infamous founder of piracy
site MegaUpload and later Mega.nz.
During its hayday, MegaUpload had more than
150 million registered users, 50 million daily
visitors, and it accounted for 4% of the entire
internet’s total traffic.
As such, MegaUpload had lost copyright holders
more than $500 million making Kim an international
fugitive wanted for copyright infringement,
money laundering, racketeering, and wire fraud.
Unlike the Pirate Bay’s founders though,
Kim wasn’t running MegaUpload out of principle.
He was running MegaUpload as a business and
a very lucrative one at that.
He had a net worth of atleast $200 million
and he wasn’t gonna go down without a fight.
Over the next several years, he would wage
one of the most expensive court battles in
New Zealand history and come out rather victorious.
He would get New Zealand to admit that they
were illegally spying on him, that the raid
used excessive force, and that the seizure
of his property was unjust.
And to this day, 11 years later, Kim Dotcom
is still a free man in New Zealand that has
yet to be extradited.
So, here’s the insane story of MegaUpload
founder, Kim Dotcom: the internet legend that’s
classified as a terrorist.
THE NERD HACKER:
Taking a look back, the story of Kim dates
back to January 21, 1974.
His real name is Kim Schmitz and he was born
to an ordinary family in Kiel, West Germany.
But, nothing about Kim was ordinary.
In fact, he was a trouble maker from very
early on as he had an interest in hacking.
And when I say hacking, I don’t mean Webkinz
hacking, I mean Mr. Robot type hacking.
In his teens, Kim claims to have hacked hundreds
of US companies including the likes of NASA,
the Pentagon, and Citibank.
Apparently, he would hack into their PBX systems
which were wide open doors for him.
He would then turn around and sell the access
codes to these systems for $200 a piece.
Kim would boast about his hacking skills on
German TV but to be honest, I don’t think
selling access codes to the Pentagon for only
$200 is something to brag about.
I mean, the real person getting robbed there
is Kim but I digress.
Aside from selling these access codes, Kim
would also sell encrypted phones that couldn’t
be tapped likely to some pretty shady figures.
But, somehow neither of these landed Kim in
any trouble.
Something that did land him in trouble though
was yet another scheme with calling cards.
Kim would buy stolen calling cards from American
hackers for cheap and then sell them for full
price in Hong Kong and the Carribean.
This made him a cool €61,000 in his teens
but it also landed him in jail in March of
1994.
This would result in 11 counts of computer
fraud, 10 counts of data espionage, and several
other charges as well.
Normally, this would land someone in jail
for several months if not over a year, but
given Kim’s age, the judge would go easy
on him.
He would give Kim a 2 year suspended sentence
which means that Kim didn’t have to go to
jail.
But, if he broke the law again within the
next 2 years, he would have to serve time
for the original crimes and the new crime.
Kim had escaped jail time with the skin of
his teeth but his life was basically ruined.
I mean, he literally had a criminal record
by the time he was 20 making him virtually
unhirable, or atleast that would be the case
for most people.
Kim, however, wore his criminal record as
a badge of honor.
From his perspective, being wanted by the
police at such a young age was simply a testament
to how good his hacking skills were.
In fact, he would use this reputation to open
an cybersecurity consulting business called
Data Protect and one of his first clients
was Lufthansa airlines.
Kim likes to claim that he dazzled Lufthansa
with his hacking skills.
Other sources claim that he knew an insider
but either way Kim was soon pulling in millions
and his lifestyle would reflect this.
He would of course buy supercars, mansions,
yachts, and all the regular stuff but he also
spent a bunch of money on creating an online
persona.
You could say that Kim was the first Instagram
flexer in the world.
Kim was definitely not the most humble guy
out there which made one thing clear: he was
no longer the nerd hacker, he was now the
rich hacker.
THE RICH HACKER:
Now that Kim had a somewhat legitimate IT
business, you would think that he would play
it safe and stay out of trouble but that just
wasn’t Kim’s style.
Pretty soon, he would be caught up in a pump
a dump scheme with a company called letsbuyit.com.
Letsbuyit was basically a wanna be Amazon
back in the dotcom days.
After dotcom funding dried up though, the
company would soon by on the verge of bankruptcy.
Instead of letting the company go bankrupt
though, Kim would go ahead and invest €375,000
into the company in 2001.
On top of this, he would claim that he was
gonna bring on investors with €50 million
and that they were gonna stage a turnaround.
This would of course cause the stock to go
wild but the turnaround nor the 50 million
ever came.
The only thing that happened was Kim would
walk away with a €1.5 million profit from
the pump.
This wasn’t the only scheme that Kim pulled
off either.
He would also launch a fintech companies called
Monkey AG and Monkeybank.
To be honest, I’m not really sure what these
companies even did but what we do know is
that Kim would embezzle a few hundred thousand
euros from them which made him a prime target
for the police.
Fearful about his freedom, Kim would flee
to Thailand and stage a massive publicity
stunt.
He would claim that he had hacked into Mr.
Small Beard’s Sudanese bank account.
He would also put up prize money of $10 million
for any information regarding Mr. Small Beard.
But, this publicity stunt didn’t exactly
win him much support and so he would just
turn to faking his death online.
Unfortunatley, this too didn’t work and
Kim would be deported back to Germany and
put in jail in November of 2003.
This time, he would spend 5 months in jail
awaiting his trial before getting off with
another slap on the wrist: yet another suspended
sentence of 20 months.
Kim became convinced that what was holding
him back was Germany.
What he needed was a change in scenery.
And with that, he would move to Hong Kong
in 2003 to continue his shady activities.
He would open up a new business called Trendax
that was apparently supposed to use AI to
generate unbelievable returns of 25% per year.
But, that was complete BS.
In fact, the $250,000 that Kim did spend on
the business mostly went towards design and
theatrics as opposed to creating an AI system
that actually worked.
Little to say, no one signed up.
In fact, the company never even got permission
to accept investor funds, so it was a complete
failure.
But, while his real life fortune was crumbling,
Kim would continue keeping up his persona
online.
For example, he would produce a couple of
bizarre animations that poked fun at Bill
Gates.
In a flash animation called Kimble Special
Agent for example, he would break into Bill
Gates’ house and write the word Linux on
his walls.
In another film called Kimble goes Monaco,
Kim would go on vacation only to constantly
catch Bill Gates spying on him.
This was mostly just satire at the time but
this has ended up being surprisingly accurate.
But, while these films got Kim some internet
points, the truth was that his real life was
quickly falling apart.
In fact, he had stooped as low as going to
airports just so that he could take pictures
in parked airplanes.
Clearly, he was desperate and this desperateness
would transform him from being a rich hacker
to being a criminal hacker.
THE CRIMINAL HACKER:
In 2005, Kim would officially change his name
from Kim Schmitz to Kim Dotcom and this marked
the beginning of piracy days.
He would change the name of his IT company,
Data Protect, to MegaUpload and launch a website
centered around file sharing.
Honestly, he was pretty early to the whole
file sharing thing, so he could’ve easily
created a legitimate file sharing platform
like Dropbox which was created 2 years after
MegaUpload.
I mean technically, if you ask Kim or especially
any of his lawyers, they’ll assure you that
MegaUpload is indeed a legitimate file sharing
platform that has no intention of breaking
copyright regulation but you can take that
for what you will.
Whether it was intentional or not MegaUpload
would become one of the largest piracy sites
in the world only beaten out by the likes
of the Pirate Bay.
No one knew that it was actually Kim Dotcom
behind this company though.
You see, Kim had registered the business under
an alias called Kim Tim Jim Vestor in Finland,
so as far as the public was concerned, it
run by some random Finnish dude.
But, while Kim wasn’t getting any of the
credit or notoriety for creating MegaUpload,
he was definitely getting the cash.
The company was pulling in hundreds of millions
of dollars, most of which ended up with Kim
as he owned 68% of the business.
He finally had the money that he always claimed
he had and he would use this fortune to buy
his way into New Zealand.
You see, by purchasing $10 million worth of
New Zealand government bonds, he would get
himself placed into the high investment category
of immigration.
And once he was in, he would purchase a $24
million mansion just outside Auckland.
But, the truth was that neither New Zealand
nor his neighbors were happy to have him.
And Kim’s efforts to joke about his past
with his neighbors just made him look worse.
In fact, he sent a letters to his neighbors
with the following “First of all let me
assure you that having a criminal Neighbor
like me comes with benefits.
Our newly opened local money laundering facility
can help you with your tax fraud optimization.
Our network of international insiders can
provide you with valuable stock tips."
Let’s just say his neighbors didn’t find
this humor to be very funny.
But, while New Zealand wasn’t a fan of Kim,
the internet very much was.
And when it was revealed that he was the one
behind MegaUpload in 2011, he cemented himself
as an internet legend.
He would go onto expand the Mega empire by
launching Megavideo, MegaPix, Megalive, Megapay
and so on and so forth.
But as far as the FBI was concerned, all of
this was just a Megafraud.
On January 5, 2012, indictments would be filed
against Kim for racketeering, copyright infringement,
and money laundering.
And two weeks later, New Zealand’s anti
terrorist squad would descend upon Kim’s
mega mansion and shutdown MegaUpload.
MEGA.NZ
After the raid, Kim would be thrown into prison
at Mt.
Eden where he spent a month before being released
on bail.
He didn’t have much to return to though.
His wife would divorce him shortly after and
MegaUpload was completely shutdown.
Not to mention, much of his property other
than his mansion had been seized by the police.
But, despite the bleak situation, Kim would
fight back.
His first goal was to take down the New Zealand
authorities because without their help, the
FBI couldn’t really do anything.
Fortunately for Kim, this wasn’t too hard
as the authorities had broken a lot of protocol
due to pressure from the FBI.
For one, they had been illegally spying on
him for weeks.
Two, they literally came in with an anti terrorist
squad.
Three, they unnecessarily seized his property.
And four, they turned over this illegally
seized data over to the FBI.
Kim’s lawyers would retaliate through all
four of these bases and more or less humiliate
the authorities for this raid.
After about 5 years of this, New Zealand would
back off and simply agree to settle with Kim
for an undisclosed amount.
The FBI, on the other hand, was not looking
to settle by any means.
They were looking to extradite Kim to the
US and charge him with every copyright law
they could think of.
But, this requires going through a pretty
lengthy and often deadend extradition process
which the FBI is still dealing with to this
day.
Will he ever be extradited?
Well, only time will tell.
In the meantime though, Kim went ahead and
launched yet another file sharing platform
called Mega.nz with a couple of cofounders.
And to really rub it into the face of authorities,
Kim would launch the site exactly one year
after MegaUpload was shut down.
And to be honest, Mega.nz is a pirate’s
dream.
Unlike torrents which uses a peer to peer
network, Mega uses a server client network
which makes it substantially harder to identify
pirates.
Also, everything is end to end encrypted which
again just makes it even harder.
Little to say, Mega was a massive success.
Within the first hour of launch, they would
attract a 100,000 users.
Within a few days, this would grow to a million
users, and within a few years, this would
grow to 35 million users.
Today, Mega has over 200 million users and
stores 107 billion files.
Now, with all that being said, I want to note
that Kim is no longer involved in Mega and
Mega is very much trying to move away from
this association with piracy.
They’re more than happy to takedown copyrighted
material from their platform as they truly
want to be seen as competitor to Dropbox,
Google Drive, iCloud, and OneDrive.
But while I wish them the best of luck in
this transition, the reality is that a lot
of pirates still use Mega.
In fact, there used to be a full on subreddit
called megalinks with over 30,000 links.
And after reddit took down the subreddit,
the community just moved onto other social
media platforms and even their own dedicated
websites.
So, Mega definitely still has quite a bit
of work to do and hopefully they’re able
to.
But in the meantime, Kim’s initial presence
is still very much weighing down the brand.
KIM’S LEGACY:
Since leaving Mega, Kim has experimented with
some outlandish things like experimenting
with politics.
He created a political party called Internet
Party but this didn’t really go anywhere.
In fact, the party only won 499 votes in total
in 2017 election.
There was also rumors that he was gonna launch
his own cryptocurrency but that never came
to fruition either.
Nowadays, it seems like Kim has just been
sitting at home gaming and enjoying the remains
of his fortune while his lawyers work to prevent
extradition.
And to be honest, that doesn’t sound that
bad at all.
I should also mention that he’s actually
really good at gaming.
In fact, he was the number 1 Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 3 player in the entire world
before the police raid.
So, maybe he should try his hand at streaming,
but then again, maybe it’s better that he
just continue laying low as at the end of
day, he is indeed the internet legend that’s
classified as a terrorist.
Do you think Kim belongs in jail?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’d like to see more
videos about internet legends.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.